Hello!
Hi!
There's a lot of Pano Mimi mousepad!
It is!
Ta-da!
It's so cute, right?
It's a buba!
Shake in my desk.
Bubba.
a mouse pad.
But it's like one of the flatter ones, right?
It's just like, no.
There's no support here.
Um, hope you're doing well, Minky.
Hope you have good gotcha luck.
Thank you.
Recoup some of those shipping fees, right?
uh uh a surprise stream yay yay um i got some stuff in the mail and i thought maybe i shall unbox it i couldn't wait i was too excited yay yay yay um so we're here and we're gonna unbox and this is gonna be fun let me show you what i got first um we'll be going in game order so
um so we have 10 so these boxes I have three boxes and then I have two also sorry my gloves I washed them but they're so gross still what did I do last time I don't remember anyway uh I have three boxes 1, 2, 3, and they are...
All...
All characters, I will get them.
Everybody here.
Here.
I should at least.
That's like, that's what they said.
But...
But!
But, but, but, but, but, but, but, so we have one.
We have two.
We have three.
Which is a little smaller for some reason.
Wow.
It's like Girl Scout cookies.
But there are...
There are...
Two games that I could not get the box for.
So each box comes with ten.
I bought ten of each.
in an attempt to get everybody from Peace Walker M4.
So these are the gotchas for real.
These are the gotchas.
These are the real gotcha.
Is that a cinema roll desk mat?
It is.
My Koharu one is stuck in...
Hmm.
So, I will obviously take these out, but We won't do these ones last because they're the actual gotcha, but as you can see, there's many characters.
We do not want him.
And then...
Oh, sorry, the light is so strong.
Uh...
We do not want her.
No Huey.
No Naomi.
Yeah.
No Huey.
No Naomi.
The irony of unboxing characters from Metal Gear, which is well known for their boxes.
Oh, it's so true, right?
No, Huey.
No, Neobi.
Say it with me.
No, Huey.
Wait, I think I wrote it.
No.
Well.
No, Neobi.
No, Huey.
Good luck, boss.
Salute.
I'm saluting you.
I'm saluting you, you can't see, but you know.
Oops, all Hueys.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, Naomi, no, no, Naomi, no, no, Naomi, no, no, no, Naomi,
no, no, here but that's just oh oh no it's uh oh i gotta take off guys want to see something cool
did you hear that that was the sound of the box falling
one moment please One moment, please.
I gotta find the box.
Where did it go?
Oh.
Ah!
Ouch.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's good.
We're calm.
We're chill.
We're cool, connected.
Everything's good.
And when I ordered, it came with this sick sticker.
Cute.
So cute.
My mouse is delicate.
What do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
My mouse is delicate.
Small?
Sorry,
there's cat hair.
Okay, let me open this.
Uh, oh, I was gonna take off my gloves.
No, Naomi, no Huey is the new Kua Bara Kua Bara.
Kua Bara, or warding off, instead of lightning, we're warding off Naomi and Huey.
How's it that?
It's a small mouse?
that small?
Uh.
Placing my best on getting at least two Hueys.
Don't do that to me!
One moment, please.
I like my mouse.
I don't think it's that small.
I mean, it's maybe a little smaller, but it's like so... It's like the best mouse I've ever owned.
My old one broke and I got a new one.
I love this mouse.
Gamba and the gamba.
You mean the gacha?
Whoa!
Whoa, they're red.
Whoa, who will we get first?
How do I open this?
Oh, there's a little flap.
Who are these characters?
Are they from one of your Japanese anime's?
I think we're gonna get...
Otakon!
Because you sent that!
Oh gosh, the stickers.
You guys look first.
Who is it?
I was right!
No way!
I suddenly want to get Otakon first!
No!
Freaking wait!
That's crazy, look.
Uh-oh.
I think I just used it all.
And now we won't...
Now we'll only get...
Okay, I'm gonna put the, like, the standy over here, but I'll leave the character right there.
there next 10 naobies I will if I'm already dead but I will kill myself again somehow Psycho Mintus is real yes
surprise stream what are the odds opening a solid Minto probably like in a million
Hello?
Thank you for the supertats.
Believe, boss.
Believe.
Gray Fox?
You think it's Gray Fox?
In three, two, one!
That was a genome soldier.
He's so cute, though.
Look at his head.
His head is... Oh, you can't tell.
I'm sorry, I'm too lazy to focus it.
Ah, Genome Soldier.
180 IQ, Dufus.
Next.
Oh, what did I...
Oh, okay.
Next, next, next, next.
Oh, I forgot to read out what characters we can get.
Let me do that real quick.
So we can get Ocelot, Psycho Mantis, Liquid, Vulcan Raven, Genome Soldier, Snake, Atacon, Grey Fox, and Emeril.
I forgot to say, sorry.
Next up is Ocelot.
All right.
Ocelot is in here.
What if it's not Ocelot?
I kind of wish they had a thing for Mei Ling.
Because she had a 3D model in...
What's it called?
VR missions, but they pretty much stuck to anybody.
Only the people that have the models in.
Oh my gosh.
Look at this.
These are so tough to rip.
Only people with models in the games.
Thank God no Naomi or Huey.
Well, Huey's not in this game.
But luckily, we don't have a chance to get another Naomi.
Honestly, if I get Naomi, I'll...
Maybe they torture it a little bit.
What did we say, Vulcan Raven?
I see Pete.
Oh, oh.
What do you see?
Wait, is that Gray Fox?
Gray Fox!
Oh, it looks so good!
He looks so cool.
They look so good, the models.
Or, I mean, obviously, it's just from the game, but...
Gray Fox, baby.
Gray Fox.
Next, next, next.
I apologize for being wrong about Ocelot.
Yeah, I molested Gray Fox, I'm so sorry.
Sorry to him.
After Zanzibar, I was taken from the battlefield.
Neither truly alive nor truly dead.
Who is it?
I think this is Vulcan Raven.
Nope, I think it's liquid.
I could tell from his legs!
Did I miss a birthday?
Oh, my mouse is not there.
Sorry.
That's embarrassing.
I turned another year older today.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course!
Eric, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
I really like your keyboard, by the way.
Thank you!
I can't remember what it is right now.
I can't remember the model name right now.
I've said in a member stream, but I cannot remember.
I'm so sorry.
Logitech?
No, no.
Or this?
Logitech.
Keyboard?
Not Logitech.
This is something else I can't remember ever.
I'm so sorry.
It is all glowy.
Yeah.
And it sounds good too, hold on, oh, I did it again.
Hold on, let me, here I'll do a little sound test for you guys.
Can you hear
this?
Hold on, let me move my mic closer.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
I think I saw someone.
Is Big Boss supposed to have the same jacket as Liquid and 1 and 4?
Or is it just a coincidence?
Does he?
I'm looking at it.
Is it the same?
I don't know.
I think it's the...
K99 something.
That sounds right.
That does sound right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, so we have Otakon, Genome Soldier, Grey Fox, Liquid.
How many do we have left?
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Oh, yeah, because I opened four.
Math.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my gosh, why can't I?
Do you think snake that he wears?
Oh, snake that he wears in four, that trench coat, I think is just like a beige trench coat.
I think.
I don't think it's like a...
I don't remember what big boss wears at the end.
I'm scared, you guys.
What if I get two Naomi's?
What do I do?
I trust we'll get every single character.
I trust.
Here we go!
It is!
Can you tell?
By their feet?
Uh...
By the feet.
Wait, sniper wolf?
Yeah!
It's sniper wolf!
We got her, we got her.
Wish dollars to fund future gamba.
No!
It's like that one account, that Twitter account that will identify people by their feet.
Me, I know.
Actually, I cheated.
I saw the little tippy tip of her gun.
I cheated.
I'll admit when I'm...
When I'm...
Ugh!
Because I'm playing dirty.
Go!
I am a phony, I know, I know!
Okay, what about this one?
Oh!
Oh, this is Psycho Mantis.
Yeah!
See, I can tell.
Okay, that one I didn't cheat at all.
That one I could tell.
That one was easy.
Mantis!
You see the new diecast figure of Rex.
Oh, wait.
Yes?
I definitely saw the new Grey Fox.
That's not diecast, though.
Metal Gear.
Rex is the name if you're interested.
I will look it up later because I can't quite.
You like water park simulator, don't you?
Chokokin Rex.
Is it good?
Is it like...
Is it...
Is it like... does it light up?
Is it fancy it has led lights it does oh my gosh okay awesome okay can we tell who it is from their feet wait my bad let's see i think it's vulcan raven actually this time yep i was right i'm maybe too good at this i may be too good at this baby We only have just a few left.
I really want to get through these so that we can get to the actual gotcha, you know?
But you know how we...
Oh, we still haven't gotten...
We still haven't gotten one particular person who will be...
This one's Naomi.
Can you imagine if if they accidentally put like MGS4 now?
They'll what if they're I kind of wish they had like secret characters in this too Nothing wrong with being interested in feet Says you says you Open Open Look I got it all crumpled up Open Okay, I got it.
I'm strong Can we tell from their feet?
Who are we missing?
We're missing Meryl?
Snake?
An Ocelot.
I can't believe we haven't got Snake yet.
Just kidding, we got him.
Speak of the devil!
Okay, this is empty now.
But I have two left.
Stealth.
Camo Soldier is the secret one.
That'd be silly.
I think Ocelot is holding out on us.
I think he's gonna be the very last.
Because Desire Meter, right?
Desire Meter.
No.
I got him!
Oh!
And that means our girl Merrill is last.
Can you imagine if that was like covered and hold on wait where's my
Wait one second
Okay Let's see if this shows up Looks
just dirty Ew It just looks like...
It just looks gross.
It's okay.
It wasn't like a...
What's the word?
It was just chapstick.
It wasn't even like a lipstick.
Hectoplasm everywhere.
I know!
Gross!
Gross, gross, gross.
Gross.
Minky slaver.
Not the authentic Otaku grease smear
I'm not very good at opening these, you guys She popped out And that's our MGS1 cast Yay Yay everybody's here Everybody's here mistake.
Oh, even the genome soldier is so sweet.
Everybody's here.
Yubi!
Okay, so that's our first box.
Our second box to go through.
Metal Gear Solid 2.
Oh wait, this also has tape on it.
Where's Decoy Octopus?
Yeah!
Where is he?
They included everybody from Foxhound except him!
That's so sad!
I also wish that they had like little ones of the actual Metal Gears.
Like having one of...
Rex would be incredible.
The DARPA chief!
All of them could be decoy octopus.
So true!
Hold on, I'm opening these real quick so that I don't have to keep taking my gloves off.
You pulled 10 decoy octopuses in me.
Oh wait, Yanwei, I just saw your other one.
Better luck next poll.
How did you pull so many decoy octopuses in a row?
Push this aside.
Okay.
Alrighty, I'm just two, two, two, two.
Who do you think we'll start with, everybody?
Are these ones going to be blue?
Oh, they're so pretty!
Oh my gosh, they're such a nice shade of blue.
Whoa!
Wow, okay, so this, for these we can get Raiden, Snake.
Wait, can we get Pliskin?
No!
No Pliskin.
Otacon, Emma, Vamp, Fortune, Ocelot, Olga, Solidus, and Fat Man.
No Rose!
What's the point?
No!
No Pliskin!
No Rose!
First pull is vamp.
Okay, let's see.
I'm nervous.
Luckily with these boxes, we know we're getting every character, so...
Sorry it's not the more fun gotcha, but we gotta save up for the fun gotcha, you know?
We gotta get through the unfun gotcha.
It's fun to see who we get, though, you know.
First pull Otakon again?
That would be crazy.
Is it Otakon?
Oh, close!
It's a sister!
Wow, she's so...
Like, her acrylic is so skinny.
We got E-E!
And the stand is also blue.
It's so pretty.
Eee.
Close enough.
Yay.
I'll put the sticker right there.
Eee.
Does it have a bird?
It does not.
I thought it might be like on her shoulder or something.
How?
I miss you.
Jennifer, how?
Jennifer, how is here.
Oh, oops.
No bird.
I ate it.
Solo bird acrylic.
Right!
That would have been awesome, too.
Oh, this one seems kind of fat.
Fat man?
Oh, no, it's solidus.
I'm so sorry, my president.
Why is he giving such like Sephiroth vibes?
You know?
That's my president.
Solidus.
No, that is not Solid Snake.
But this is Solid Snake.
I'm calling it here.
Alert the presses.
Solid Snake is in this package.
Solid Snake!
Solid...
Solid Snake, I'm gonna get you...
I'm gonna get you out of there!
I'm gonna get you...
Okay, I got it.
I'm really...
Snake, I'm getting you out of here!
Wait, there's no soldiers for this one.
No Grilukovic soldiers, huh?
It's kind of sad.
I guess there's so many characters and two?
That'd be hard to like do every single one.
Snake!
Olga!
We got Olga!
No, that is not solid steak.
Sorry.
Her standy is also so skinny.
You might be asking, Minto, where are you gonna put all these?
Hey.
I'm gonna take my glasses off now.
Yeah!
Snake looks a little different.
He's pregnant now.
And pregnant.
Yeah, because Olga's pregnant.
Who is this one?
Who is it?
Let's see if we can tell by their feet.
Oh!
I saw a sign!
I love when I can just grip them, you know, when I can...
Yeah!
Like this.
Snake- I don't like that word.
That sounds weird.
Snake listens to Minto karaoke confirmed.
Emprig.
No!
What are you talking about?
Who do we have left?
We've pulled four.
So we have six left.
We have Ryden.
Snake.
Otacon.
Fortune vamp.
Fat man.
I think this one's fat man.
Fat man In here Fat man in your area
It's fat man It's fat man And if it's not fat man It's a fat man My fat may be his dumpy It's snake It's snake It's snake It's snake It's snake It's snake
I knew it was a fat bag.
I knew.
Am I good or what?
These stinking stickers, man.
They're fine up until the very end.
What's up with that?
Jack, welcome back.
Snake cake.
Oops.
You guys want to guess who it was?
Equivalent of the vulgan grip.
Yes, that is so sick.
Fortune Fat Man.
I'll have
to find it amongst the debris.
Yeah, here he's in my hands.
He's in my hands.
Or she?
jump scare.
We got vamp.
Where'd my box go?
Here we go.
All right, that's four left.
Four, four left.
The bisexual!
Okay.
I'm not even trying to be...
I'm not even trying to be gentle anymore.
Okay, there we go.
Who could it be?
Feet?
Fat Man?
Oh, to God.
God, we haven't got him yet.
It's like the opposite.
Skinny man.
Biny baby ghost freaks it and struggles.
No, I'm not.
What do you mean, baby?
Wow.
You need scissors.
61.
So now we need fortune.
Batman.
Riden.
Why do we keep not getting the main person?
until the very end you know tiny baby tiny baby you say huh tiny baby
we're dramatics do you think it's gonna happen like that with the other ones too I'm nervous who have we obtained so far for two we've gotten Otacon, Emma, Olga, Ocelot, Vamp, Solidus.
And now we have...
Standy!
I just...
All of these are gonna...
All of these are the same stand...
Yeah, they are all the same bases.
I just realized.
I've been putting them all in like a pile, like this.
And I was like, wait, what if the bases are different sizes?
But they all seem to be...
The same.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I was like about to say...
Wait, I might have screwed myself.
I think...
This is fortune.
Wait, can we tell by the feet?
Yeah, it's fortune.
Yay!
Fortune, fortune!
Gosh, she's so sick.
Let's see...
Nice!
Ryden's holding out on us.
The big gun.
My matron!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the pig!
We get your favorite iconic line from each character you've pulled!
I don't know.
Oh gosh.
Every single one?
Maybe from...
Maybe from here.
I think I got fake gacha packs.
My packs only had Stilman and Jerome's.
No Stilman here.
That guy's blown up.
But I wish we had...
I wish I had a Grilukovic soldier in it, though, too, to match the genome soldier.
You can totally tell who this is.
Entirely from the feet.
That is a fat man.
Wow.
Fat Man!
La-ha-ha-ha.
Laugh and grow fat.
Ha-ha-ha.
Hey!
And that last, but not least, is our boy.
Is our...
Is our boy!
Blue packets are mesmerizing.
I love blue things.
I know.
They look nice, right?
The blue color is so...
It's so pretty.
Last but not least.
Come on in.
Come on.
So cute.
That's my favorite line from him.
When he goes, So cute.
Yay!
That's all from two!
That's all of the standies from two.
All for this and Saucy Jack.
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay!
Alrighty.
Next up we have three.
I didn't buy, they have Delta ones as well, but in one, in some in some Delta pre-order that I got it came with all the acrylic so I did not buy these ones but I think the ones I got came with Eva and then these packs come with Tatiana which is kind of interesting last but least this is my mouse pad it's an artist Panamimi and this is original character of hers.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One of the many Delta pre-orders.
Yeah.
Can I humbly request a celebratory hand wiggle?
Like this?
Or like this?
My hand wiggle?
Next.
Three.
MGS3.
So with this, we can get Snake, the boss, Eva, Young Ocelot, Vulcan, Sorrow, Fear, and Pain, Fury.
I like how they put all of them on this side.
Everybody else on this side.
Oh my gosh, Vulcan's holding the Davy Crockett.
That's so funny.
No Cobra unit?
You spoke too soon.
Where is the parrot?
It's on the end!
It's right there!
There is!
The parrot's here.
Oh, whoa!
These ones are green!
Green, green, green, green.
Green, green, green.
Oh, wait, I accidentally took two.
This one.
Green.
I thought they would be like a darker green.
They're like lime green.
Makes me thirsty.
I can't wait to get the Fury I love his design so much Least favorite boss Well, I want to say least favorite Most frustrating boss, but I don't know I think my least favorite quote unquote is The pain because I don't like swimming But Fury I just I do like the fight.
It's very scary though.
Makes me scared.
Tommy God!
The pain is annoying.
Yeah, I don't know.
I don't like swimming and it's not like super exciting of a battle.
So I'm glad that it's kind of first.
Who do we get first?
Tell by the feet?
I can't tell.
Can you guys?
Start finishing MGS a month ago and finish one through three, but it's the best thing ever that's happened to me.
Solitary red.
Thank you.
Welcome.
You think it's snake?
Eva?
I think it's Eva.
Eva!
Ladies first.
And this is the standee.
Wow, it's really green.
Or it's really bright green.
It's really lime green.
Lime, I miss her.
Oh, I was like, what do I do with the box?
Okay.
ladies she's i know i was gonna say she's the only lady we have but no we have the boss also there's a severe lack of women in this game i guess maybe if you want to count eva and tatiana as two different people but maybe
boys club they make up for that in four true oh paramedic yeah there's paramedic Right off Yeah Like give me at least Oh no you know how they make up for it You know how they make up for it With all the gravier posters With all the gravier posters That's how they make up for it Let's see Oh I think this is Vulgan Yep I could tell from his big old boots I could tell Look at him with the Davy Crockett
Remember the aloe vera.
I bet if I kissed you, you'd taste like a wild beast.
Why did she say that?
I'm gonna start trying to open from this side.
Okay.
Can't help but see the craw cat.
He's not wearing it.
Oh no, I just tore open my box a little.
No.
Because she's right.
I guess so.
Some kind of judo.
Okay.
Who do you think?
This is the end.
I could tell because it was so fuzzy.
His pants were so fuzzy.
Yeah, it's the end.
With the parrot.
Tastes like a wild beast.
Absolute best line with the crocsuit.
100%.
Grandpa.
The end?
Stream over?
No!
That's our first Cobra unit.
Do you hear me?
Snake.
I like me, says that part.
It's so epic.
It's like, just like a really awesome moment.
You think it's the fear next?
Let's check.
We shall check.
I'm like really tearing these up, aren't I?
I was like, is it the box?
Oh,
it's the sorrow Nope, it's the boss What's the sorrow look like?
Oh, it's close-ish It's kind of close Why is this Why this pose?
Why?
Like, why she...
Why did they choose this?
It's so strange.
Naruto run.
I said the sorrow, but it being the joy, kind of... kind of fits.
I uh...
But I like now, since I thought they had a similar pose, they really don't.
Like...
They really, they really don't.
Wait, they're right next to each other.
But it's because their legs are lifted, you know?
Hmm.
Oh, sorry.
I have, like, a focus on the back of my camera, so if you hear me pushing it, that's what I'm pushing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
I'm tearing up the whole thing!
Okay.
There we go.
Easy peasy.
Should get a letter opener.
Alright.
I'm also kind of disappointed in Orykov.
It's her bum-rushing snake.
Yeah, I know what it is.
But...
Oh.
I can't tell.
Fear?
Oh!
It's psych!
Yeah!
I didn't know his pants were so baggy.
Oh, hi Snake!
I'm so sorry!
It's Snake!
Oh, there he is.
And all his glory.
Okay, I'm excited.
After this one, we get to the real gotcha, you guys.
After this, real gotcha, real gotcha.
These ones we know, since it's the...
Boxes, we know that we're getting everyone, but...
Okay.
What's that stance?
Let's go gambling!
Not solid snake.
I didn't say solid snake.
Yes, that solid snake.
Oh my gosh.
My fingers are starting to get tired.
I wonder...
Do I have any scissors?
Do you guys mind if I run and go grab some?
My thumb is starting to get sore.
I'll be right back Okay, I'll be right back Give me one second Give me like one second Give me a second Go get Uh I'll be right back
I'm back I'm back I'm back I got scissors Okay Now Easy peasy time Easy peasy time How do I should I do it?
Oh this is easy Yes Ah, it feels so good.
It's so clean.
Oh.
Thank you, thank you.
Just be careful not to accidentally cut the contents.
Bees.
Many bees.
Look at all the bees.
Nah, we're good.
They're acrylics.
They'll be fine.
Bees, bees, bees.
We got the pain.
I like how it includes his little bees.
There's so many of them.
They're so cute.
Tommy God.
Oh, oh.
Okay, what do we got here?
Cute scissors, thank you.
Something happened to me last Saturday.
I had a couple miles to go.
I looked over my phone and saw what?
I saw that.
Wait, hold on.
Saw a glowing VTuber on my phone and I recommended she was playing MGS1 very irregularly.
Who could it be?
Oh.
And suddenly there was an intense light all around me and when I came to I was home and watched your entire first playthrough of the MGS series from three years ago.
Three years ago!
You were pretty good.
Three years?
I've been gone.
Are you confusing me for someone else?
But thanks for thinking I'm pretty good.
Oh, that's a lot!
Oh, my...
Why is he posed like this?
It's for me, isn't it?
It's just for me.
Oh my god the camera doesn't want to focus because he's too handsome.
Oh my god.
It doesn't want to focus because he's...
I want to do this to him.
Okay.
Can't wait to see your oscillot shrine.
There's like a sad amount of of Ocelot merch.
Oh, this one's big.
This one's big.
Who else is?
Who do we?
Fury!
Yippee!
I was like, who could be so big?
The Fury!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, he's so cool!
He's so good!
Love, love, love, love, love.
Love, love, love.
So I guess then...
Oh, oh, yeah, never mind.
I was okay we have two left two left two left who do we not have sorrow and the fear that's it thank you so much for the thank you thank you for the good to get the thank you thank you so much oh my gosh thank you thank you thank you okay oops oopsie oopsie oh
sorrow sorrow all right and then that leaves the fear the fear is the last one fear I have to have so much to clean up man it's all on my ground on the ground I've just been throwing all the things on the ground I should be like putting them back in the box or something nope I'm just throwing them on the ground fear fear
And that's MGS3.
Hehehe.
Yay.
All right, guys.
It's time.
Which one should we do first?
Let's do four first.
Let's go in, like, game and release order.
So for those who were not here before when I explained this, the first three boxes, I, uh, I was able to get the full boxes.
And, uh, and the full box comes with every character guaranteed.
But for Metal Gear Solid 4 and Peace Walker they were sold out at the time they were they're back in stock now but they were sold out at the time and so I was just like well I will just get 10 of them like I'm pretending to get a box so here we have 10 for Metal Gear Solid 4 who we can get we can get Old Snake We can get Otacon,
we can get Sunny, we can get Ryzen, we can get Isolat, we can get Naomi, we can get Vamp, we can get Eva, Big Mama, we can get Drebin.
I've got, why Drebin and not like Johnny?
We can get Drebin and we can get Meryl.
Incoming multiple Naomi's, no, no, no.
Please read the pinned tweet.
I mean, not pinned tweet.
A pinned comment.
No Naomi, no Huey.
So this is our first one.
Hot dog.
Hot dog indeed.
You hate ship Naomi and Huey.
Oh.
Oh, that's like a crack ship if I've ever heard of one.
Okay.
No Naomi, no Huey.
This is the actual gotcha, you guys.
This is where we can get dupes.
We're praying for one of everybody except Naomi.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I was so scared for a second.
I was...
I saw...
I saw a lady.
And I was like, no, no.
No, no, no.
It's Big Mafa.
Oh, gosh.
I was scared for this.
And then the base is black.
I like it.
It looks really nice, actually.
Okay.
Oh.
Holy.
Okay.
Alright, Big Mama off the list, baby.
Let's go.
Okay, I don't want to look at, like, what their poses are.
Because I don't want to...
I want to, like, guess, you know?
I don't want to see him too much.
And...
And no.
Merrill?
Okay,
we are already at a dupe.
That's fine!
We just...
need to get everybody else except except except Naomi we just need to get I can't believe the first two are dupes I cannot believe this I cannot believe this if anyone needs a big mama please trade with me I I could tell the media I saw it We got Drebben,
10 times Big Mama.
How come you get two mobs?
Solid Mama and Liquid Mama.
Okay.
Just realized this is kind of reflective.
Ooh, scary.
Okay.
Gotta be careful with these ones.
But Naomi is very attractive.
No!
No, she's not.
This is not Naomi.
Oh, it's Menfeet.
Men feet.
Otacon!
Oh!
Okay, we got Otacon, we got Otacon.
Okay, I really just want Snake.
I really, okay, I want Sunny Snake and Ocelot, obviously.
And I wanted Otacon.
So we are one out of four of the people that I really wanted.
So far only one dupe.
Not bad.
Out of four?
Could be worse.
Okay.
Oh.
I can call Minto Q and she won't see it because her notif Q is clogged.
Requesting healing beam.
Also awful flu today.
Nicholas, no!
Beam!
I think this is snake.
Oh, we're so sorry, Meryl.
It's Meryl!
It's Meryl, it's Meryl!
One, one, Naomi's special deluxe.
Now!
Okay.
Not a dupe.
Oh, oh, gosh.
I think Snake's feet are together, together actually now I think about it.
I feel like I recognize his pose the most.
Alright.
Oh.
Wait.
Riden?
No.
Oh, oh, I was like, Ryden has heels, though.
Oh, it's VAMP.
VAMP.
I was like, because I saw, like, little grippers.
Oh, gosh.
You see it?
You see the spiky grippers?
But Ryden has heels, so I was like, it can't be him.
I forgot about VAMP, to be honest.
This is good.
This is good pulse.
so far.
This is pretty good so far.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
All right, all right, all right.
Okay.
All right.
Sunny snake, come home!
Ocelot, come home!
Oh, I did the same thing again.
Oh wait, I think this is sunny.
It's really short.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, she's so small.
Look at her!
What?
Oh my gosh, wait.
If I line them up, look at how some mouse...
Stop, it's precious.
It's so cute.
Oh my gosh, it's too cute.
It's so precious.
Okay, we have three left.
We have three left.
We're missing Snake, Ryden, and Ocelot.
Snake, Ryden, and Ocelot.
And who else?
That's it.
Ocelot?
I'm predicting Ocelot.
lie now.
Thank me later.
Wow.
I'm not thinking yet.
We got dupe Meryl.
So we got dupe dupe Big Mama, dupe Meryl.
We did really well though.
I'm not gonna lie.
We did crazy good.
We've done crazy good.
Is this Otacon?
Snake or awesome.
alive.
Am I not gonna get snake or us alive, please?
Please.
I think it's gonna be snake because he's been holding out on us every single time.
Except three.
But he's been holding out on us a bunch.
So I think it's gonna be snake.
I think it's gonna be snake.
Trust.
Trust old snake.
Old snake.
Grandpa come home!
You're charming.
is so strong you're pulling double women yeah everyone that we've got every double every dupe we've got is a woman ssr look okay okay oh fucking monkey ah ah
Open monkey!
I don't even remember the monkey's name.
What?
Mint?
No, it's not.
It's not Mickey.
Well, well, well, team.
Little Gray, my Oshi.
Little Gray.
Oh my gosh, poor girl!
Spending my birthday alone this year.
I'm super happy my Kamioshi.
That's the design of the street today.
Thank you for staying with us through the chaos of the last I will give you my gotcha look, but I don't have any more guru!
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much.
Thank you for the hot chocolate soup, but thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday!
Thank you, thank you.
Monkey's name is Kevin.
No.
Alright, so, team, if you also got these...
Um...
If you got these...
like Sandeeps as well and you would like to trade a Drebin, Otakon, Meryl, and Big Mama.
I am in search of...
I kept... I didn't get Naomi though.
Oh my gosh.
No Naomi!
I am in search of Snake, Otakon, Ryden.
Those three.
And Naomi.
I want a full set.
Ah, man.
Next convention I go to.
I'll bring them with me.
Yeah, I'll bring them with me to the next convention I go to.
And if you have, if you bought your own and have snake, old snake, Acelot.
Yeah, I guess that's Holiday Matsuri.
Holiday Matsuri.
We have Snake, Acelot, Raiden, or Naomi, I will take those four.
Alright, but we're not done yet with the gotcha.
We're not done yet.
We have another.
We have one last set.
Peace Walker.
And in here we can get Snake?
Amanda?
Chico?
Paz?
Cecile?
Oh my gosh, what's his name?
The bald man.
What's his name?
I forgot.
Wait, yeah.
Hot cold man.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
I'm such a fake fan!
Hot cold man!
Zadournob!
And, uh, Strange Love, so...
Yes.
We will try.
We shall try!
No Huey.
No Naomi, no Huey.
I wonder... I guess it's gold, the base for this one.
Oops, I accidentally cut into the...
Cardboard?
Oh, oh, oh, oh,
Amanda, Amanda, and then, wow, it's really yellow.
Peace Walker.
Amanda, Amanda, Vinceremos!
Vinceremos.
If anything, I want, if I get any dupes, I would be really happy with dupes of Paz.
Really happy with dupes of Paz.
I want, I'm fine with, I'm fine with losing hot, cold man and Zadorna.
And Huey, obviously.
Just letting you know that 10 unique polls from 10 possible results has a 0.04 probability.
I don't care what the probability is.
I don't care.
Streamer luck.
Oops.
I did it again.
Oh, Cecile!
The lady who was introduced and never heard from again.
Kaminandes.
Kojima Kaminandes.
Come on, let me pick up my trash.
Kojima is God.
She likes birds.
We're getting all the women!
Which means Paz is coming up, baby.
Paz is coming up.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
No.
Who else is thick?
It could be snake.
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
And it feels really different from these two.
No, no, no, no.
I'll put this one last.
I'm in denial.
Denial.
Denial is a river in Africa.
I gotta turn this over.
There's...
Uh...
Cause?
The doorknob!
Rocket peace!
The doorknob.
Rocket...
Oh my gosh, I'm making a huge mess.
Oh, here too.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, here.
I'm making a huge mess.
Okay, but that's three for three?
Three for three?
Okay.
Oh, why are these ones so hard to do?
The other ones are so easy.
Can't get it in the hole.
There we go.
No.
No, God, no, God, no, no.
You guys look first.
Oh, wait, I don't think it's Huey.
Oh!
Oh,
pause.
Pacific Ocean, my beloved.
Oh, I'm so happy already.
I'm so happy already.
I'm so happy already!
Ah!
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, she's so, oh, she's so beautiful.
Oh!
Hot dog indeed!
Pause!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh, I'm so happy already!
Uh oh.
Snake!
Snake, snake, snake!
I went!
There's legs!
Wait, I think this is the doorknob.
Oh, it's Kaz!
Wait, I said Kaz earlier for the doorknob and now we got Kaz!
I've completely... I've got them.
They're very similar.
Their toes are very similar.
He's got a bit more of a heel.
Yeah!
Guys!
This is crazy!
This is good!
Oh my gosh!
Nice shoes.
Oh!
You're a suit.
Okay.
It's pretty bendy on the sides.
Stop feeling them.
You're spoiling.
How am I spoiling when I keep thinking that they're, that they're all, I keep thinking they're all Huey.
Okay.
Oh?
Uh, what's his name?
Hot Coldman?
Hot Coldman!
If you could design an MGS figure like a character in a specific pose, what would it look like?
I would do Paz's idol outfit.
There's one picture that you can get as a poster in V.
And I want, I want that as a figure.
I want that.
That figure.
That as a, as a figure.
I want that poster.
That poster as a figure.
But the, I want that.
But also, of course.
I got to get Ocelot doing that.
But I don't think I would be able to look at him, you know?
I would be too nervous.
Uh-oh.
Guys.
Very minimal bend.
Uh-oh.
When did...
When you started the silly military stealth game, did you ever imagine it would rot your brain?
No.
I did not imagine at all.
Uh-oh.
This isn't cheap.
I'm cheating!
Oh no, wait, wait, wait.
This one actually has more bend than this one.
Oh wait, this is the last one.
Oh, legs!
Zadornov, our first dupe.
Oh, it had no bend!
It had no bend, you saw that!
That's crazy!
Our first dupe is such a lame guy.
You guys, I'm a guest at Holiday Matsuri.
And you know who also is going to be there?
Steve Blum!
Yeah, the voice of Zordnov is going to be there.
I'm going to ask him to sign my Peace Walker copy.
Chico?
Chico!
He's so tiny.
He's so small.
Am I not going to get snakes?
you guys okay so who do we have left all right we need snake and strange love and I have two left I have two left and I have two people I'm waiting on why can't I get snake
two Hueys no don't say that
Oh, I just want Snake.
Please.
I want our big boss.
Your love for MGS is one of the reasons why I enjoy watching you.
No way!
Kwe said thank you.
Snake.
I think it's hot, cold, man.
It's true.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
No, stinking way!
Holy, holy cow!
Trust.
If this is Huey...
If this is Huey, I'm ending the stream.
If this is Huey, I'm ending the stream!
Ah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get in there, please.
Get in there.
Hold on.
Come on, stick!
Ah!
Thank you.